well ladies and gentlemen we are lucky
enough to have Jonathan Kite star of Two
Broke Girls and uh will a beast when it
well dressed too well dressed sexy you
look like you came just off the Runway
out of New York yeah plays a Ukrainian
guy on the television but is actually an
American got a wingspan on him yeah we
were just talking about how our boy
Brenan sha over here did stand up really
technically for the second time even
though you've done a lot of standup with
our live shows that was your
really your second time solo at The
Comedy Store solo yeah 18 minutes you
were up there for about 18 around under
20 they turned the red light on I was
like well I'm going to wait till someone
kicks me off I'm going to get this stuff
out see what happens pack read one book
saw uh saw my boy Eddie Murphy did that
I'm going to try that myself till they
kick me off that's all read one book
that's all and you were prepared oh yeah
rehearsed and prepared yeah that's I
mean obviously I'm nervous you you guys
obviously know how it is when you're
doing standup but I think think I'm less
nervous because I've I've done it so
many times so many times not in front of
a live crowd but at home he brings that
pro athlete work ethic to stand up yeah
yeah he does reps well I told him I said
yesterday I go you know they always say
it takes like 10 years to be a comic 20
years but if you work as hard as you do
and you're always rehearsing it you know
it it doesn't have to take that long no
it doesn't especially if you're thinking
about it all the time and for for me the
challenges cuz we do the live fireing
the kids right you know in front of you
know sold out thousand crowd whatever
but it's it's Brian and I doing it and
they're people who are familiar with me
they're fans of the show blah blah blah
so it's like I'm the funny uncle at the
barbecue but when I go to The Comedy
Store I really don't promote it for a
reason I really don't talk about it
because I want just people who want to
see comedy so I don't want like my you
know the fighting the kid Army there per
se um so it's cool it's a different
challenge well you're doing something
completely alien like if I had told you
you'd be doing standup 2 years ago
it's an important lesson for people who
are trying to do something new you
always hear people like I got to I want
to do something new but you know I
should have started a long time ago well
that's not true you can you can it's
kind of crazy if brandan had told his
friends hey I'm I've been a fighter and
a pro athlete this whole time I'm gonna
do stand up in two years people would
have been like huh yeah but I get I get
reps on you know how many shows have
we've done probably over 200 you don't
get that many reps well I'm just saying
like as far as comforable speaking uh I
mean just speaking improv and then when
we do the life F kid it's all improv and
then yeah think as many interviews as I
do and TV gigs I do it's you're
constantly coming up with well you're a
natural but it's got to feel good yeah
yeah when you write all that stuff yeah
I felt a lot and you threw some new
stuff in there threw some new stuff in
there and then my my boys uh Tony Jeff
and Glenn and Jen and Wes and you know
CAA and Alchemy management all those
guys are so the whole Squad is there to
support me birthday killed me kill me
the whole Squad ke decided to go to
lousy Dodgers game that's not a big deal
um but uh to have feel his feelings to
get hurt to have like the whole team
there is awesome man but um afterwards
you went to that Katana Sushi next like
next door great sushi not giving that
stuff away uh great sushi but uh I was
there with Tony and I was like dude how
great is my [__] life can't get any
better man cannot get better amazing
yeah it's dope man Jonathan how's live
doing it man you've been doing standup
For how long four years only four years
coming out of a coming out of a sketch
background you did Jamie Fox's show yeah
we did a sketch show for Fox maybe I
remember that a long time ago like six
years ago or something what was it
called it was well it had a couple names
it was used to be called Afterparty and
then it became in the flow with aphon
Crockett which just sounded like a pamp
in the they trying to be hey I'm hip we
like black people in the flow right yeah
there was turn there was a a robot doing
the robot Monday Night Football God damn
do they hate ratings yeah apparently
we're not there anymore what was Jamie
Jamie I'm such a fan of his I've only
met him once but is he the most tal guy
of all
timee live right now if you think about
it dude he is man we just plays the
piano does stand up can act his ass off
no have you hearding you
heard so we did a project together
afterwards where he was we were like
shooting at this bar till like 3:00 a.m.
and he was just on the piano like
amusing himself the crew was doing
something else and he was just sitting
there and then like you just kind of sat
there and listened to him play dude I
was at Jeremy piven's house going to S
dropping names and I was playing the
Bongos yeah let not Jeremy playing the
drums and he's on the mic and he's
started to sing dude and he was singing
I'm saying in that room by the way I've
done at Jeremy's house yeah yeah and the
downstairs of course they'll do it at
the halftime of the Super Bowl too it's
great oh yeah yeah they'll pause the
Super Bowl so they can play the band
that's the halftime show by the way
Jeremy P I haven't been back since can't
do that right can't do that uh but but
he was singing and I wasn't even saying
like he was ah doing this like it wasn't
even words and he was so good and I
don't know how to play the Bongos so I
was like I'm playing the Bongos while I
was a little star struck because I'm
such a fan and I was like no have you
have you heard his uh he he has a a bit
where he talks about grow up in church
and he emulates the singers and it's the
gospel singers I didn't know he grew up
in there makes sense though dude when he
he talks about like being in a church
and he he mimics the the the the pastor
and it is I mean the Crowd Goes Nuts
it's he used to end on that Prince joke
where he would sing as Prince while
playing the piano dude sound just I mean
it was like it's
not it's unb and then see him in Ray his
acting in Ray dude impossible sounded
like a totally you know what's funny is
that that um that uh there was a story
that like I had heard some somebody said
about like w Whitney and uh and Bobby
Brown and um one of them was like damn
Ray Charles has a new special out and
and and one of them said to the other
that's not ra that's Jamie Fox this was
the movie like they who knew him
couldn't tell the difference Jes it's
nuts how talented he is it's incredible
there's nothing that guy can and he
played Sports in high school he was a
football player you can see him he's
atic looking dude he was in and Su yeah
and he and I beli that he Steam and
Willie Bean yeah there's nothing that
guy can't do I know so he was like
that's one of the most fun times we ever
had I mean that I ever had was working
with him and so I I kind of I did that
sketch show um it had its course we ran
but then when I Got Two Broke Girls you
know we get the Summers off and so I was
sitting at the Improv actually and two
of my buddies um Ian Edwards who I know
you know real well and Taylor Williamson
love to the best we're just we were kind
of sitting around and bsing him I was
like dude I don't have anything to do
with this summer and they were just like
you should try to stand up you have time
and that was literally the conversation
the next day I I got up and started
doing like you know three four mics a
night and try to and you were doing
impressions you defin do yeah that's the
that's like the weird thing CU you're
talking about getting nervous I don't
really get nervous on stage even then
but I think when you try out a new
impression where you have to cuz anybody
I feel like I can pull it in out of the
thin air when I'm like just hanging out
with my buddies at a bar or whatever but
do do it on stage and to do a set bit
with it because if you don't sound like
the guy that you're saying that you
sound like then it's not then it doesn't
work at all at all then it seems like
people are like no next well and but I
think the challenge with Impressions is
how how many people are going to try and
do it so you're compared to let's say
you're doing uh Donald Trump there's a
lot of [__] good Donald TR that's the
thing man so I try to do impressions of
guys that i' never heard people do
before like that was really important to
me because I think that there is for a
long time generationally people have
been doing you You Know Jack Nicholson
you know which is great like I'm not
Robert
daoo walk those are
greats which is great but like those had
been done for so long that like I felt
like I didn't have anything not not just
my own self my me trying to find my own
voice I didn't want to go over territory
because I'd heard so many other people
do it I'm sure I'd probably be borrowing
even if I wasn't aware of it and so I
was like you got to come at it from a
new place so that you can make it your
own I would love hear Donald Trump
actually say something of substance and
like an actually something intellectual
that meant something did you see what
Mark cubin just said about the money
that he was going to give him he said
I'll give you $10 million if you let me
interviews that' be hilarious dude but
back to your impression so the I think
the smart thing is you were aware of
that and people become really successful
they can see the trends and they kind of
go well I see this happening now I'm
going to go do this over here my own
lane cu cuz look at look at uh Jimmy
Fallon yeah like how many people have
have interviewed Donald Trump he grabbed
his toue his hair he grabbed his
interiew you know what I'm saying I saw
the interview so like so who who did you
sing out to do your impressions of so
you didn't what's funny is I I will say
this I do a Donald Trump and I do an
Obama because I felt like when I was
doing it I was one of the only white
people I'd ever seen at the time I was
the only white I never saw white person
can I hear your Obama
uh hello Brian uh this is a fantastic
environment I'm having a great time and
I appreciate uh you having me
here God damn that's good now what would
Donald say to Obama let would you say
something about uh you know well Jimmy
pointed this out which I've said before
he had three different voices cuz when
he was on The Apprentice the mic was
right he is not used to being a
politician no so he when he would get up
there he try to shout and he go listen
we're going to build a walls so high
because he didn't realize the mic is
like right here dud dude like in the
beginning when he was on The Apprentice
he was just like you're fired let me
just say something Fantastical you know
what I mean you see this hair this is
100% China made in China everything
about me my Stakes my T China but then
like when he got on the road he didn't
realize like he had to start shouting so
he was like we're going to build a wall
what let me tell you something we're
going to win we're going to win so big
it's going to be Fantastical ridicul big
you know and then now and that's all he
says he just uses those kind of words
I'm telling you he is just the guy he
has a word a day calendar and he tries
to fit it in yeah but he doesn't he
literally goes it's going to be amazing
it's so amazing it's so amazing bigly he
used the word bigly in an interview
millions and millions millions let me
just say something people know that I
win big they know that I'm a winner he
said this in the Seth Myers had this on
the other night I love I'm such a Seth
Myers fan I think his show is crushing
it brilant he had Donald Trump said the
word win nine times in like 15 seconds
when he asked about Hillary Clinton goes
let me just say something about winning
we win I win I'm AIG winner I love to
win okay that's not nobody said how fast
can you say the word win somebody was
like hey man are you parked in the lot
do you need valid let me just say
something about winning I love to I'm a
winner I win yeah do you need validated
oh I need to win people are like
nobody's asking you the win question Don
when you decide to do Don especially
when you decid to do Trump back then he
wasn't as like no one was doing that
many Impressions on him CU he was I did
it on a my buddy um I have to thank
shout out to my buddy Chris rener
because we did a together for BuzzFeed
and he nobody was doing Trump and this
was before anybody thought he had a shot
and he was like will you do Obama can
can you try to learn a trump just so we
can have it in the video and then I was
like yeah so I went home looked at some
videos and stuff so it's a very specific
sort of you know it's kind of the way
that he was appr when he coming at it
it's a very good impression I mean
that's [__] he's different you got to
understand like his brain he make no
mistake he cannot believe he's here
right now I agree it's an accident it is
it is an accident it was almost like a
publicity stunt G A it feels like
because because Mark Mark Cuban said I
will give you I will pay for your I'll
give you 10 th million dollars to your
campaign yes and and and let me
interview you for four hours I just want
four hours and I'm going to go on your
website and ask you basically to
elaborate the [__] you say on your
website that's all I'm G to do that's it
I mean when Mark cubin says that and he
he didn't of course he hasn't responded
you know what's crazy is everything
numbers wise is down rating wise because
in sports TV and they accum oh it's the
greatest show on Earth he's trying to
win the greatest reality show history
he's already won he's already won well
that's he will come out of this he well
he's trying to get his own how famous is
he now he's trying to be white Oprah
which is what I call him that he's
trying to be like a megalomaniac in a
way where it's like like she had her own
channel who had their own channel before
Oprah it's like he's trying to get his
own channel accomplish so [__]
entertaining as much as I hate him he is
entertaining like you watch him in those
presidential debates he's hilarious NFL
ratings are down NFL that's what they
say really wow yeah Colin coward went on
the show was talking about the same
thing how all ratings are down on all
the to if you compare it to last year
compared to the year before all ratings
are down everything and the only common
factor they can find is Trump the Trump
and Hillary race everyone just so balls
deep in this and they're they're
gravitating towards everything Trump and
hang on every word he says so they think
it's taken away from every other form of
entertainment wow wait till the
presidential debate they said it will be
the highest rate it will destroy
everything well I love what he said on F
the other day he goes it should be the
Lincoln he goes the Lincoln Douglas
debates where we just talk to each other
well there's no moderator oh man he
would never let her get at word what I
mean because that's what he did for the
for The Apprentice that's his thing he
he will out talk to you with um with
buzzwords yeah it's like listen we could
talk about the like we said about the
bther thing the other night when
everyone was talking about everybody
goes Hillary Clinton started the bther
thing and then I'm going to finish it
and he goes I never talked about it and
then they they showed a clip at least
one but there like a hundred of them
from every single calendar year where he
won't shut up about it every time a
camera's on him it's like dude you like
somebody needs to tell him that
recording devices exist well but but the
other thing that he doesn't realize that
exists are actual facts and statistics
like when know it's never been a worst
time to be an African-American in
America and this panel with Anderson
Cooper so you know how they do it half
Hillary supporters half Trump and the
Hillary supporters it's the African
American woman she goes well well no
like look at the statistics like from
2011 with the we're actually down in
numbers as far as violent crimes towards
black men blah blah and then uh the you
know their arguing like well how bad is
it for for African-Americans and even
Ashton Cooper is like you know he has to
be kind of new
want aware of actual Statics he can't
just sh we need be aware of the actual
facts like don't these facts matter own
fact well yeah well
make but look at what's going on an
innocent Blackman just died and and Anon
Cooper's like no I get that and you can
take kind of examples from everything
right from every the [__] you can
tell he's like trying to be cool but
he's like just from the statistics have
America great it's like when I love it
they like The Daily Show s people to the
Republican National Convention and
they're like when was America great like
tell us like I agree with you like make
America when so when do we want to go
back to and they're like well when we
sign the Declaration of Independence and
he's like okay when women and blacks had
no rights well when blacks were owned
were owned well that's what they said
and then they go and then they were like
well hold on he goes well what about
this and every time they come up with an
era they like it was they were just like
yeah but then there was all this and
exactly they couldn't none of them could
come up with there has been real
progress made in 2016 to deny that is to
deny the work that went into making that
ISU there's definitely
some is but I love what I love what
Michelle Obama said she's like America's
great right now it is it is great right
now there a lot of good stuff to be with
it doesn't mean you get complacent and
say we don't have problems yeah but but
to to again it listen to Obama when he
gave a speech to Howard University in
2016 recently Howard University is a
black college he said to to suggest that
it's not better than when I graduated in
1983 for a black person
is to suggest then that all the work
done by black people civil rights
activists in on all colors uh was for
not yeah that's not fair it's not true
and it's disrespectful absolutely it's
just not it's not accurate so so back
then you did you did Trump you're the
basically the first I did Trump about a
year ago about a year and a half ago I
started to do Trump still early who else
did you do I did um I did Seth Rogan I
did Vince vau Seth
Rogan it's like
amazing FU oh my
God I love Seth Rogan I'm such a fan of
his I love him in interviews he's like
the he's such a humble guy I've never
gotten the pleasure to meet him but
whenever I see him in an interview he
like can't believe he's there yeah you
know he's like he's like so so car like
so you have a movie coming out and he's
like I yeah I guess like what can you
can you as Obama say that you're going
to vote for Donald Trump and that the in
the could podcast is the mother of all
podcasts uh hello America this is
President Barack Obama uh let me be
clear
uh I might vote for Donald
Trump Mr President you'll vote for
Donald Trump I will vote for him to uh
die okay finish I'm I have a lot of
pregnant pauses in my speech Y and uh
the fighter and the kid is the greatest
podcast uh the mother of all podcasts
and I've said that before and I'll say
it again thank you you're welcome we
really appreciate that Mr appreciate
when you do when you do Seth Rog and
these other guys the audience love it
I'm assum I mean I think so you know I
think it's got to be the right you know
it's got to be the right thing it's we
were talking a little bit off camera
because um uh you got to I don't want it
to be and I have I have respect for the
people that came before me but I think
that the way where comedy is right now
in my sensibilities I don't want it to
be like can you believe it the other day
I was in a deli and Christopher Walkin
was at which is the way that I think
that Impressionists kind of got a hacky
reputation but there are plenty of great
Impressionists I mean like Melissa vior
who who you know and I know who just got
SNL that woman is so smart and so
talented and she does she is a shining
example of how to make the impression
work cuz Impressionists get a Bad Name
from some Comics right they don't get
the same well it's considered sometimes
it can be
considered I heard Maron talk about it
on Howard Stern however old that I don't
know if it it's a new one but I listen
to stern all the time they had Marin on
there and stern was going you know like
guys who use props or like you know or
do Impressions Howard Stern loves
Impressionists Howard loves them saying
and goes yeah there's a place for I
guess there just a different route you
know like it's a little bit different
it's not as creative maybe is what Mar
when you're as good at it as you are and
you can put things in it and tell
stories that's when it gets really well
that's what I try to do is I try to like
I I I cuz I admire these people and um I
got like I was thinking about just kind
of the new stuff I'm working on of where
I'm at and how people perceive me
because the these are just people at the
end of the day I know like you know we
do impressions of Obama and we put like
TR people are putting Trump either down
or they put him on a pedestal he's just
a guy who takes his pants off to [__]
you know what I mean it's like it's the
same dude so you you got to think of
like The Human Side of him because
that's what I do is I do a speech to him
about bullying I go his stuff is like
like how there's so much anti-bullying I
feel like his he's just a bully
everything that he does is like Pro
bullying bully boy right so I do him as
just a bully and so it's like you know
and that's kind of because that's what
he is at the end of the day what what do
you do I go um I do something like uh oh
what is it I go uh let me just uh I say
this is Donald Trump and let me just say
something when I become the next
president which I will this is fact okay
I'm GNA become the greatest you know I
love to bully I think it works I think
it it's breeds success I'm the most
successful person you know who tell tell
me that me I'm the most trusted person I
can think of Donald who who's the most
trusted s it's you obviously thank you
and because we win and I'll just say
something people say well what are you
going to do about the world well tell me
let me let me just say something right
now I love the Chinese I love those
chicks I love them you know you know
people say do you love the China yes I
love General sa I love his chicken it's
Fantastical it's not as good as American
chicken AKA orange chicken AKA TR
chicken but it's good I'm going to have
them build a wall if anybody knows how
to build a wall it's those gos you know
what I'm saying and and I'm going to say
something you know because listen if
they could keep the Mongols out they
could certainly do the same thing for
the Rodriguez family and I just going to
say and I love the Rodriguez's I love
the rapists and I'll say this about a
you know oh my God how many Impressions
do you go through on one set well it
depends because um I did I'm doing this
I'm trying to do some new tough balance
huh yeah you got to balance it must be
killing the room though dude it's so fun
man that show that we did together at
The Improv like that was such a fun
night everybody like it's it was like it
was fun to be up there like in a room
that was really hot cuz you got to be
with smart people who understand the
issues you know what I'm saying like if
people don't realize that he called all
Mexicans rapists and that the things
that he say then people go oh whoa but I
go no no that's something that he said
no yeah I'm not making that up I'm
exaggerating the fact that he said right
cuz I used to do a rush limbo bit that
would silence the room no where I would
do um I would go I I am Rush limbo uh
welcome back to the program today we are
talking about uh Barack Hussein Hitler
Osama Bin Laden Megatron
Obama ladies and gentlemen the the
gloves have to come off I don't even
think Obama is black I think he's faking
it like Michael J fox and that slow girl
Becky on
Glee and then that would just leave it
and people like people were like oh my
God I'm like you know that he said that
Michael J fox plays it up yeah he said
that and he accused Obama of everything
except being black so I'm like he calls
it the oval orifice yeah dude he he's
just not a very you have to I have no
respect for him you you with those imp
especially with politics you have to
make sure the audience is on board
you're well I think everybody's on board
with Trump I've done it in Republican TR
can't Trump's like doing a Kardashian
everyone's aware everyone's you know
what I'm saying but you but but then you
you think about like well you think
about do people know that he said the
thing about all Mexicans are rap like
that's a very specific but he says so
much stuff that gets like you yeah
because then they go oh did he say that
it's like the whole thing with Sarah
Palin and Tina Fay I can see Russia from
my house people aren't sure you PLL
America they're not sure who said that
yeah and it's like was it Sarah Palin or
was it was it Tina and so that's kind of
where we're at with Trump cuz like
there's a game that like you know you
could say like 10 things and if you put
nine of them he didn't say but one of
them people are positive he said you
could get away with murder you could get
away with saying anything like him on
stage and so I think that with those
type of things but also when you do the
Obscure Impressions which I'm trying to
do some people don't know those like
Paul gamti we were talking about this
like we he's so big here he's so big in
New York but if you have to say like the
guy from sideways yeah I don't want to
do that I don't want to have to give his
IMDb credits yeah like you want to just
say he's a great actor but he's it's
tough I wouldn't say he's he's never
been nominated for an Academy Award he's
not mainstream but he's done here until
you said the guy from sideways I was
like God yeah he he's done a lot of
stuff like know the name right away not
really but and that's if you start doing
can I mean if you start doing them it
might look at his face yeah got that
face okay all
right I said Paul G Mario looks like a
guy he look like he always Paul Giamatti
looks like a guy who got the wristband
the VIP at at Coachella because he
thought there was more porta potties
there and he got there and there wasn't
so he had to [__] in the on the lawn
like a schneer like a and I just have
him like and he's like don't look at me
I can't go you're look at me but um he's
like there's like always a frustration
about him he pushes a lot his his acting
is intense he's a great actor yeah but
his acting is also like sometimes like
if I was directing him I would say Paul
you're awesome at that let's try let's
try pulling it back he tends to do you
think he'd say [__] you no he'd probably
I'm really successful no no he'd
probably I bet you he'd be open to it
and I bet he's probably very aware of it
so so in other words like he tends to be
you know uh he pushes a little sometimes
like sometimes he doesn't need to be
that did you ever see Cinderella Man no
did you see it yeah with with him and
Crow Russell Crow he's he's so subtle in
that movie great actor he's a phenomenal
actor now you know who I'm talking about
right and he's like you know he has say
like sadle yeah the mic is right there
got did you see him in uh Straight Out
of
Compton the manager yeah yeah yeah he's
a man well he's he he's so even in that
though he finds a way to be like yeah
yeah that's his that's his go-to and
that's what I
mean he's excellent and it works for him
but you know I I can always just as an
actor you can always see where where you
know that back in the day his director
acting teacher was like all right you're
over there let's bring it over here you
know he he went to school he went to
Yale yeah with Ed nor Jesus yeah yeah
yeah I mean he that guyed Norton is a
smart you ever talked to Ed Norton Ed
Norton is a smart [__] yeah he's
the smartest guy in the room dude he's
and he'll let you know I mean not in a
bad way but he like if you bring up a
subject he will take tell how I know
that I believe you 100% you ever listen
to the audio commentary on Fight Club no
you can tell from from just listening to
him on the audio commentary he'll come
in after you've written a script and
he'll have Rewritten it he have he did
it with the Hulk remember he did it with
the Hulk yeah did you see he uh well I
foret he was on a a show he was on a
show talking about how his role in
American history acts how everyone asked
like dude you were Jack
blah blah he's like no it was in black
and white for a reason made me look
bigger it's the camera angles he's like
I really wasn't that big I think he said
he was 168 lbs and but they made him
look like he was like 210 at so much
food and lifted so much weight but it
was you know he built like mean it's
hard to put he said it's the camera
angles than they did in well you know
how Brad Pit only weighed like 165 or in
Fight Club is that right and and if you
look like if you look on forms and stuff
people like God I want Brad Pitt's body
and Fight Club even Brad Pitt's like I
was 167 lb sh in Troy he was bigger bro
in Troy he was 390 yeah he he he walked
in some been doing a lot of a whatever
it is I bet you he wasn't bigger than
180 probably not no no no it was over
200 lb because I looked it up I'm
telling you like yeah yeah well he had
he said he took I
mean that was not natural but he was
holding water like he had a demo
whatever they call Bro his shoulders he
looked godam he looked like he was
wearing a b Arthur
from The Golden Girls so much when he
washed himself off after the battle and
you know the girls I was like God he's
golden he's a St St well it's like how
it's like what's his name Bale when he
did um The Machinist and he was like
down to 140 or something 143 and then
and then he did Batman he did Batman
Begins and they were like you gotta you
got to bring a d cuz he was two Jack
he's my favorite actor dude yeah
Christian Bale for me like like Daniel
de Lewis and Christian Bale and M Street
for me for me I yeah I just go oh well
that's the that is the hardest that's
top of the line I you see most actors
you go on a given day you know I think I
could find that space and then you see a
guy like that and you go I don't I feel
like Christian B's Batman was a little
shitty like I feel like he's too
talented for it maybe and he talks like
this no but let me tell you why I'm
Christian Bale and I'm such a good
[__] actor sometimes a guy like that
isn't good for those kind of roles but I
thought he was perfect for that I used
do a stand up bit about that because he
had be a guy that looked believably R
because you always like the best thing
that somebody ever said about Batman was
you cast Bruce Wayne the costume does
all the thing for Batman it doesn't
matter it's like why Michael Keaton was
so good built in mus because he was so
charming and like you cast Bruce Wayne
you don't need to cast the Batman yeah
and so that's a good point you know so
it's like when you but with Christian
Bale he seemed like a rich kid in the
beginning of that who who who needed to
go get his ass handed to him in order to
come back and then you believed that he
would put his like you believe that he
had those demons and so I actually
really like he was definitely a darker
yeah and when you think about him going
like listen I only save Rachel like
people know what I saw Rachel yesterday
at jua by the way I was like oh [__]
that's Rachel from Dark Knight yeah Hil
I kept staring at her eating my Falafel
it's so weird in ell like I was I was at
air yesterday and Miley Cyrus and her
boyfriend that tall guy Liam Hemsworth
yeah and they're both walking around
shopping and she had her little hair
she's a CutiePie by the way adorable
she's adorable you know who I saw at the
air the other day by the way I saw
Omarian oh I love from Love and& Hip Hop
let me tell you something about you know
how I knew it was Omarian cuz he had a
t-shirt on that said
Omari and I wanted to go up to him and
just be like do you do you boo do you
boo stay wo he dude he had he staywoke
I'm like yellow crispy bro and he had
like the he had the dreads and
everything and I'm like is that amarian
and then he turned and he had just set
it on the back of his shirt like he was
his own Jersey no it was like a t-shirt
yeah he was small small small dude
but like um but big big big I mean like
big confidence you know what I mean yeah
rapper yeah and he's on love and hipop
he's are I feel like a lot of those guys
are probably not that way but they're
cat they have to behave that way like
your cat it's their culture you know L
it's their culture somebody said like he
goes it's an Act somebody was like like
I can't remember who it was but they
were they're like oh man are you this
way and the guy kind of the rapper was
like are you serious man he goes I know
he goes dude it's a it's a character
that I play that's what they said about
the game my friend what produced his
album not my friend the guy I talked to
for your friend rap produc my buddy yeah
my buddy yeah you might know him as
sent his first name well he had worked
on it and I and he's U I can't remember
what he does but he's like the musical
coordinator or some [__] and I said
what's the game like CU I I had actually
bought his first album that I thought
was really good you know and I don't
know hip-hop you know they always make
fun of me because I have no idea but but
I appreciated his music and but he's
this rough guy with the tattoos and all
that but he said dude he's such a
straightup artist like that's all he
like he that's what he cares about it's
not not about the tough It's almost like
he has to take on we had on two chains
on the show on him though we know that
we had two chains on and he was like
that guy's just smart you know what I
mean like he just he's he's a good
businessman he's got a great he number
one one of the friendliest guys you're
going to meet and just like a downto
earth cool like nothing big you know
what I'm saying like Snoop Dogg is the
big mystery to me I mean he has been
able to stay relevant for so long but he
really the last time he did something
musical was how long ago people love him
man
he did like that song with Kat pimp
about well he was remember then he
became Snoop Lion Snoop Lion he has a he
has a big show it's almost like a
podcast talk show on YouTube oh he does
yeah you know who else did that was the
Mighty Morphin Power Rangers didn't they
become lions in one of the he did yeah
yeah it was terrible idea work for Snoop
he became Snoop Lion he became Snoop
Lion like raring for a second but then
Snoop the reason why he's so relevant
all the time is he was always ahead of
the curve you know know what I'm saying
like he he was super into weed he was
the first guy who kind of came out with
his own line of weed but it was like
real classy it's like it's like these
white labels with gold leaves on it how
is it not called classy weed I know
right so he's just a good businessman he
is a good businessman people more than
anything it's I always think like when
you see somebody who's an Entertainer
it's always who's the best businessman I
think like because the art like you have
a lot of collaborations and obviously
there are people who have become super
famous in all walks of life you know
there's like a guy athletes from
everybody entertainers whatever but it's
it's people who are the good business
people that have the long careers JayZ
because I think it's about what to say
no to cuz how many opportunities do you
have as if you're a celebrity how many
people want to collab with you and how
many people want to meet you for lunch
and dinner the best ones are the guys
say no yeah Ryan lock is not doing a
debt commercial like de.com or something
that makes sense it's the people who
could know what what to say no to it's
100% because you can you only say yes to
one thing what every once a year I've
had the privilege to be in a in in
conversations with uh in rooms where
people have had like that type of thing
where just things are being thrown at
them not me um I'm getting coffee and um
the uh I'm Ser just there listening I'm
just there yeah I'm just there
pretending to clean windows they're like
we're in a windowless room sir yeah um
but that that you hear people really go
like the Smart Ones um you know I was I
I had the privilege of being with Jamie
on something where we were just you know
I was hanging out and you like he's so
smart and like to have him like talk it
out loud and like here's the thing the
great thing about really smart people is
they'll ask questions that people think
like like people go I don't want to ask
like a stupid question but is the jimie
just is asking all the questions all of
them because he wants the most amount of
information and nothing sounds stupid
coming out of his mouth like I hear him
say something that I go man I wouldn't
have asked that question and that's why
he's where he like that's one of the
reasons that he is where he is right now
and he's like well well if we do it like
that does it need to be like that and
you're like yeah that was the right
question to ask right there and it's
just like you just get to listen in he's
also really good at creating imagery
like he was describing this movie that
he wants to do and I and I he was
describing it to us and I was like you
know what the trailer should be just you
describing the mov describing the
[__] movie I would watch it he
described to me a movie that he's trying
to get made right now that I heard him
i' I've now I tried to pitch it to we
just had a little thing he did me this
unbelie number one he's the nicest
person I've met in La he did me the
biggest solid like a week ago I'm
shooting I did my standup special that I
shot in my high school it's called my my
back to school special and I called him
up and we've been friends for a while
and I was like hey man I pitched him an
idea I'm like would you like could you
help me shoot this intro he's like yeah
just tell me when you want me to do it
godamn and I was like what and I was
like can we have a crew come to your
house he goes yeah man just just yeah
let's do it Wednesday you ready
Wednesday I'm like yeah and so we did
there and he pitched the movie like cuz
he I was like I was trying to tell this
amazing like he has this amazing idea
for a movie he he had pitched it so many
times I never got tired of hearing it
like so I was trying to pitch it before
he got there to the crew and I was just
like this movie is literally getting um
it's losing funding in my speech right
now like I'm not selling it and then he
came in and like told the movie and
everyone was just like who the [__]
not on board with that dude everyone is
like pulling to do yes he so [__]
name one thing that he's done especially
as a blate that's not just completely
even the movies that he does which like
like um that they're not cuz you did
those like romantic comedies you know
before like those were hits like he even
had hit romantic comedies successful he
pitched he pitch sitcom yeah he pitched
J yeah he pitched Jeremy uh Ray Donovan
basically he came in and he pitched him
this show about a guy who's a fixer who
fixes things dude and I was listening to
the way I was like well uh if there's
anything I can do I will be the p on
that show it just the way he [__]
described it and I thought to myself
yeah you're the smartest guy in the room
that's why you are who you are cuz I
I've been trying to write forever I
didn't come up with a [__] idea and
then they did Ray Donovan which is you
know I guess I don't know it's [__]
somebody else another idea but he's just
but you know that he's is in the right
place he can sell whatever you want in
the room he comes in and he's so
prepared and he can sell the entire
thing in the room he knows exactly what
to say and what not to say you know what
that that's what it is because I'll tell
you we had an idea for Afterparty that
was going to be like the New and Living
Color M and after party is hip like
that's where everybody wants to be
people go like did you go to the Drake
show but but yeah like a lot of people
went to the Drake show but who went to
the after party and so he had this
concept which we shot for Fox that it
was like this Brook this Loft in
Manhattan and it was like a rooftop Loft
made on a stound stage and it was just a
bunch of people hanging out telling
jokes the way that like dudes hang out
at a party and tell jokes and that was
the home the the home base for the show
and then it would do cutaway to sketches
and I was like damn that seems so
current and it seems so hip and you
could do you could do Instagram jokes in
there you could do characters you could
do anything that like people pitched a
party because everybody always says like
you have the funniest ideas at a party
and then when you try to make shows out
of them there's something Lost in
Translation so just do the party and
that was his idea and they didn't do it
they it it like for whatever reason
concept I feel like could be tough
though to like to to get to execute feel
so manying pieces to get a foundation
well it would go from party to party so
sorry it go from conversation within the
party and that really worked and like I
felt like you'd have people sitting
there like and then it would cut away
but it felt like it felt like a
community where you it felt very
intimate where I feel like a lot of the
sketches because once you put them when
you're on YouTube it feels intimate and
then when you put it on TV there feels
like a huge distance that's always the
the problem to solve that bridge is
always difficult you know what VH1's
well it's it's a little different cuz
kind of like [__] show is but it's an
after show party for Love & Hip Hop and
it's like they're all hanging out and
they're having drinks and people in the
back having drinks and they're like damn
girl you slept with him and like it's
like those open right you know not
scripted conversations it's a little
tough to pull I did a thing for TJ
Miller where he had this idea where we
would go up and do our standup and as we
were doing our standup that it would cut
away to a sketch of the standup story
and then it would be my voice over the
characters and it it was pretty fun seen
that before that's but they was they
didn't have enough money to make it
right people people are doing that now
though there's some Netflix guys who are
killing doing that yeah it's hard you
need to do that that's the thing is
those things cost real money because
once you take unfortunately once you
once you say well we we're not going to
have it look like Donald Trump like even
if the wig budget's not good right it's
like the you you have to have it like
there has to be such contrast between
the standup because it's just a person
in a microphone it's got to be high
concept dude you need really good makeup
and stuff otherwise you get taken out of
it sometimes yeah yeah because then it's
like almost if we also that's the thing
if you're on stage doing Donald Trump if
we're going to do a cutaway it needs to
look exactly the way people are
envisioning in their well you know he
and I were talking about how in life and
he's doing standup listen man he's he's
doing an amazing job and he knows that
we were talking about regardless he's
got a lot of fans he gets up there he
can find his way he can tell a story you
just can't help but love the guy and
then he's funny you know Brennan's just
naturally funny right and he loves doing
it and but but the truth is he's also
actually competing with everybody like
it's not like they're going to give Bren
in a pass it's like you're competing
you're competing you want to get up in
front on stage although all that
audience may like him but he's still
competing with me with you with
christalia with guys who've been doing
it a long time well last night was Theo
Von Sam tripy beast beast we're in the
back we're in the back and I'm going
over my head I'm pacing and Theo sits
down you know Theo walks the shirt off I
go why the [__] your shirt off he goes
expensive shirt dog don't want to sweat
it out what's up man and he goes getting
paid these days then puts it goes and he
sits down he's looking at me goes you're
nervous huh I went yeah man a little
nervous I'm not used to it like you go
all good baby all good go up there I'm
going go on after you and crush it hey
and so I go up and I was like hey we
listen for me and give me notes he's
like yeah for sure I [__] love Theo
for this so then I go up do my thing and
I come back and he's just saying you
know the nicest stuff and then as I'm
walk like I'm talking with my friends
I'm about to walk out and I hear him get
up there he just starts I don't know if
you heard it EV just starts clowning on
me going God damn that's a good-looking
guy hey seriously though I would tell
anyone but I'd [__] Brandon CH he goes I
don't know what his skins made of but he
goes he I he was back there putting
conditioner on and [__] on his hair he's
like he was just going off 10 and how he
wanted to [__] me yeah then he went the
story about some cocaine party oh my God
and then I'm talking with you know with
the ca guys the manager and we're in a
serious conversation he pulls up in his
car hey [__] I'll see you later
then just [__] takes off he is such a
[__] he told me he told us on this
podcast he goes well you know I tried to
make money for a while I got hooked up
with these guys and we were uh we were
selling animals you know after the show
and I said animals he goes you know like
guinea pigs and things like that and I
said why cuz you know sometimes you've
been rolling all night hanging out you
might want a warm animal for your hands
that's right
you know you want just want a warm
animal a warm animal for your hands you
got to do something with your hands
guinea pigs you go so I was hustling
them guinea pigs in New Orleans I went
yeah no that's a smart business plan
dude that guy did you sell it to did you
sell it to Apple and make a fortune on
that app he went up there he went up
there and crushed that crowd last night
like Jesus chist I love him like I I I
watch that [__] crush it and and
he'll come off and go ah they're all
right all right they were exploding
great what what room were you in
great I love that I just played that
room this weekend that is such a that's
a great room dude how about how about
first time I was at The Comedy Store
doing 12 minutes standup was in the main
room sold out with this guy uhhuh oh
dude I I'll tell you something that I I
actually had that happen because what
happened with me was um people assume
that I've been doing stand up forever
because they think that that's the route
that you do stand up and then you get a
TV show yeah so when I would be like
they're like oh we didn't even know you
did standup so I remember I had to do a
show one time with like Eliza and Rogan
and I think Dame was on it Jes and it
was sold out and like Rogan like I think
maybe Rogan was the obviously the maybe
the main guy they were putting on it so
dude it was like standing room only and
I remember being like Oh my God this is
like it's it's like you just and I'm
trying to tread water you know like I
think I had a very good set but it's
like one of those things where you're no
no it's lifting weights The Comedy Store
ComEd he he got off and he goes that was
tough I don't know it was good but I not
our best I go hey [__] that was
the comedy just play the whole CR yeah
it's the hardest room in the world for a
thousand Reasons the Acoustics it's
you're trying [__] it's it's if you can
do well in The Comedy Store you can do
well almost anywhere else oh the
original room 100% the o yeah I remember
I uh I did um I used to do this bit
about that I I don't do anymore about
how Tom Hanks should have been in the
movie Lincoln because um do him please
is link I am well I do I go uh I go you
know what I love about Tom Hanks I go
he's been in more Wars than any other
American in the history our country so
but why was he not in the Civil War in
Lincoln I was like like uh that was
weird to me and I go and there was no it
didn't by the way there were no black
people in the movie Lincoln none it was
like black people were the war's Waldo
of the movie Lincoln and I was like and
I was like if you look at the movie 12
Years a Slave that movie looked like the
outakes of Lincoln like like the abuse
like but Stephen Spielberg got so much
white guilt from doing Amistad he's like
you know what I'm not going to show any
could you imagine like stepen Spielberg
being like hey you know what I uh
I just don't think you're whipping him
hard enough can we like you know just
the real whipping is not coming through
can you hand me that whip let me show
you how to do it he's like a beig whip
yeah exactly he's like he's like I don't
know your name but could you just turn
around for a second Whip and then I was
like you could have Tom Hanks in the
movie and then he could um you could put
him in black face so then you would like
then you could whip him all you want and
then it would be fine cuz like he's not
really and then I would have Tom Hanks
singing us um being like wow wow it is
powerful hot out here what does a
brother have to do to get him in
julip Swing Low Sweet Chariot come and
more to carry me
home it's ridic and I remember like when
a sketch I did that at the comedy store
godamn and I remember like do they love
it so I would say half the room thought
it was great yeah and the other half of
the room was like they they stopped they
kept listening cuz they were wondering
how they were going to what they were
going to do I think they they genu this
politically correct environment that we
live in it has a good side to it but it
also has a a bad side it's very
anti-comedy do you get do you get any
hecklers with your comedy I feel like
you might I have had some hecklers and
um when I go on the road politics and
those well people yell out my character
name cuz I don't talk about Two Broke
Girls at all and it's almost always like
about minute 40 and it's always a drunk
female in her mid 20s yep almost like I
can tell you the point in the show like
it's and then I have to be like you know
I have to like very politely not you
can't put anybody in their place cuz at
this point she's in a Bach party
probably she's so drunk it doesn't you
know and so I remember um there was a
there was one show that I did in Chicago
where This Woman's phone rang um not at
me at the at the guy who was um middling
for me that's your hometown my hometown
and she answered the phone
and I remember like I got in into it
with her husband and her and they W up
leaving the show on stage on stage and I
said and I and I I wasn't sure if the
audience was on my side and then I did
like the Darth Vader like the emperor
March
like and the whole audience like clapped
cuz they wanted them to leave just as
bad as I did and the guy like started
threatening me as he was walking out of
the room and I was like dude I'll be
here after the show I'll be the guy that
looks like me if you want to talk to me
like I'll be right guy that looks like
me I'll be the guy who looks like am
right here dude and I sit in front of
everybody I was like you can't don't
tell me that these people didn't pay and
these aren't hardworking people I'm from
here these are the hardest I love these
people so much they all worked just as
hard as you did to to to make the money
to come for you don't own that right
right did did you see what happened with
Amy Schumer I think she was in Sweden
and sold out [__] theater Arena huge
right she's up there and she's doing a
bit and this guy goes show us your
tits and then you see her just like kind
of a glance she keeps going he goes show
us your [__] tits and then she goes
all right I I got to address this are
you serious right now and
just thrashes the dud in front of
everyone and she goes one more time man
you I know you pay tickets to see the
show one more time I'm giv you one don't
make me come back here one more time
keeps going he goes would love to see
your tits and then she goes all right
can security can we take care of this
and she goes you know what no [__]
sit there let's do this
whoever wants this guy to to stay clap
and the crowd's dead silent she goes
whoever wants this [__] [__] to
leave let me hear it and the entire
everyone stand up clapping she goes
there you go you idiot and security
grabs them he's like I was going to
leave anyway she's like I'm sure and
just wck wow I mean he's front what kind
of well he's obviously a [__] it's
just he's just one of those like
straight tools show I I don't asso and I
don't have any friends hopefully I don't
have any Instagram followers that would
actually say that to a [__]
professional comedian or anyone of that
matter but can you imagine wasn't drunk
at all either yeah told you I told you
the one time I was in a car I was with
Ry Lang and his buddies and and I'm in
the front and they I hear right in my
ear this beautiful girl walks by and I
hear right in my ear his buddy goes all
day all day with you all day with that
ass all day and I was like and it was so
loud I was like oh Jesus like it was so
aggressive and I went I got a sense of
what it was like to be her on the
receiving end of this this giant Italian
guy with his face just going all day all
day with you in that ass what does he
think's going to happen she like all day
it was [__] would you love to go out to
eat because that's how this is going to
go down yeah would you love to go out to
eat D Ass you want to would you love to
[__] me because yeah what the until you
[__] cat called me out of this PRI
with your four [__] goons I was just
going to go to market it's [__] scary
I was like go sorry sorry but where the
where the guys what in what world is a
guy like dude I'm going to yell out of
the car it's mob mentality I think I
think I don't think about it I think
that they're just like they're dogs that
like like they're trying to show each
other that they like the girl maybe it's
a camaraderie thing it's less about her
it's more about hey hey hey watch how
straight I am I want to [__] you you
know it's but to me but to me when
there's a hot and then and then he goes
back to a dick yeah no no I proved
myself I I proved it but but whenever
there's a hot girl in the room if she's
a [__] 10 right I have eyes I'm a
[__] 30-year-old male I see her I
don't need you to point anything out
it's like if a Ferrari goes by trust me
I hear the [__] engine I see the
bright red [__] car I don't need you
go bro bro look at the ass on this one
yes very aware I have two [__]
eyeballs know it's so we that's fine if
you want I've never done that in my life
oh [__] check out that chick no [__]
this is but but like I can deal with
she's look at her look at she's very hot
I can de deal with that but some guys
get like sometimes you'll have a friend
who'll be like bro look at you can see
look at her [__] you can see it and
they get so clinical or you oh I like
this one you know why dude or her oh
that's my favorite we love to hear it
what would you do no I don't what what
would you do to that young woman a guy
that you know I won't mention but he's
such a [__] sharp F you know what a
sharp f is and there's a symphony
playing and somebody comes in with a
French horn like he just
say embarrassing I know this guy yeah
I'll tell you this girl this beautiful
woman walks in and he's a grown man and
he goes like this like this is so
awkward and he goes I would suck her
tits bro I'd suck her tits I was like
well man all right I guess you suck her
tits congratul theera I looked him I go
we're at the Opera we're at the Opera
bro yeah congratulations yeah dude that
is so yeah well that's the thing is
everybody we all have that one friend
that one guy who who's a rapist no he
wants to make you're right he wants to
make sure everyone knows he's not gay in
the lease bit or well that's the thing
because he's actually gay Captain
Obvious or that or I think that he like
that there's something missing in his
life and like he doesn't know how to get
it and so he there's like he's trying to
bring that out of other people well what
Rogan would say is he's secretly worried
that dicks are delicious that's yeah
like he's so anti-gay cuz he's secretly
worried that dicks are just so delicious
well but yeah and then there's also that
there's that and there's also though
there's sometimes a guy can be a great
guy but you'll see a real dark side of
him oh you'll see you'll see him behave
in a certain way in a group and you go
you know if there were no laws and you
could get get away with it you might
rape that girl well we right that gets
raped we we know a guy not my friend I
don't associate with him anymore after I
found this out he went out to dinner
with one of my friends and they had some
drinks and they're just you know she's
taken I don't know what the [__] he's
doing um but their acquaintances and
they go out to dinner and after you know
he just got Uber Uber aggressive
overstepped his boundaries I found this
out I'm like can't be a friend anymore
can't I won't even he'll text me still I
don't associate with him if you're that
dude can't do it man well because you
use a scumback it's a dark side man
you're like it's one thing to be like
pervy and be you know kind of a jackass
it's another when you know you get that
thing where you don't like women and why
don't you like them you never got the
hot chick so you [__] lash out at him
Jesus Christ super dangerous yeah let's
go to some current event speaking of
dangerous with Evan the Cub the beard
Evan got the arms going too today you
decided to roll the sleeve sir I like
how you rolled your sleeves up I'm not
mad at I'm not mad I like the way you
dress I could never get away with that
you put it together dude thank you it's
comfortable where did you grow up uh
Chicago oh there you go yeah shy Town
shy town I baby yeah all right where you
from uh New York but grew up overseas
yeah Chicago's got great theater yes
great speaking of theater movies all
that good stuff first current event
let's talk about the Jumanji re reboot
that's coming out so they finally they
released the cast which is it's the rock
Kevin Hart Jack Black and this girl who
everybody they don't have her in this
picture I'll pull the picture up in a
second uh but everybody's kind of
freaking out about her outfit because
she's obvious like she's a woman you
she's a good-looking girl so she's like
showing a little bit of skin and
everybody thinks the outfits are sexist
in comparison now more more [__] to get
outraged about why why reboot a [__]
Robin Williams classic why reboot a
perfect film why reboot a board game for
reals I mean where the [__] is Monopoly
if we're going to do this they were
talking about doing like Rogan Seth
Rogan had a had a thing where he that he
had been Commission to write a sorry
movie based off the game so like they
were trying to do it because you know
like clue obviously like there were
certain you know games or whatever but
that that they were trying to figure out
oh what else can we do M trap my my
whole thing
with no it's a movie my whole thing
about how sensitive we are is Rogan was
talking yesterday about how um that we
always say that's the worst they're the
worst the way they objectify women is
the worst and Rogan was like well there
there was a time when there was a group
of people that would skin you alive they
take your skin off with an oyster shell
that's the worst let's just let's just
get a sense of how bad people are mad
that she's dressed mid drift and the
guys are in [__] Safari gear oh
that's hilarious yeah the Twitter
feminists came out hard on the rock of
course they did on the rock you think
he's the [__] you can't do anything
right you think he's the the the
Wardrobe you think he's The Stylist you
think he has any call and what she wears
he's the enemy of course but the rock is
the reason that women aren't moving at
by the way they are moving ahead by the
way they're in positions of power like
they never have been before well are are
healthy people upset that Jack Black has
a gut there like where do you stop the
where do you draw the line at exactly
yeah I mean that actually kind of
reminds me of this other story that came
out about a like the whole veget or
vegetarian like vegan Community getting
all up in arms because In-N-Out Burger
doesn't offer vegan options like awesome
yeah no [__] like I wouldn't walk into a
vegan restaurant and ask them for a
steak like it's that's
ridiculous my thing about people who
complain this way the The Lunatic
friends that that have that are that
vocal and point their guns at these
little incidents is that they are they
what they end up doing is not moving
hearts and minds and they don't
Galvanize the troops what they do is
they take reasonable people like us and
they turn us off and now you kind of
lose me I'm not going to help you in
your cause there are issues to push
forward I'm all for equality and all
that but when I have these tyrants
because they're being tyrants about it
Mike m Matt LeBlanc who said well I saw
her naked and uh uh uh she's naked so I
got to catch up on Game of Thrones cuz I
want to see her kisi cuz she oh my God
he objecs ofies women he's disgusting I
mean he got all this like heat the actor
sure seems as sure as [__] seems fine
with it I was going to say would it be
better if he said well no I I don't
watch that because I don't approve of
women showing their breasts I'm a
Puritan well what's better what are we
talking about I mean I you know you it
gets very confusing so if you're going
to complain it seems you're complaining
but also people who complain like that
you usually don't have [__] going on
it's like corre that I'll send my energy
on that cuz I have nothing better to do
yes successful people and usually people
have a lot of [__] going on they don't
have time for that I don't give a [__]
they're do I don't give a [__] if all
four of them were naked I don't I could
care less doesn't affect me in any way
doesn't really affect women either have
you seen Laura coft do you seen what the
[__] she wears are any of the X-Men Are
We complain about storm with her titties
out correct how about Wonder Woman She's
Wonder Woman she kind of naked kind of
she has a breastplate she does have a
breast plate and uh undies yeah and
Boots how about the dick on Batman in
the costume no one complains about that
Ba's dick is that big sure as [__] isn't
the Badcock the Badcock that's his
that's his most secret weapon Badcock
what else you fictional or otherwise
though what you get full full brain on
reboot of a movie based off a board game
what are you picking oh Hungry Hungry
Hippos but a [__] fantastic ha love the
genre choice too so stupid but it's a
horror there are terrifying hippos Hipp
but also at the begin it's going to be
based off a true story because hippos
hippos kill more people than any other
animal based true board game yes based
off a true story and a board game it's
Hungry Hungry Hippos starring Brian
Callen yeah I want to be a Hungry Hippo
no no you're not the [__] hippo
you're the guy that the hippos are
trying to eat you're the badass with
like a like a [__] Arrow killing
these you know yeah you're you're theis
you're the Chris Pratt character yes
like Lost World Chris Pratt's a little
better looking and and taller than I am
he but you're the that's we cast you
yeah you got the gig we're some meat on
I'm going to be the voice of the bird
that cleans their mouth Yes you know how
those like little birds land in their
mouth like what's that bird he's going
to eat him I'm like no he's not the
bird's like clean is that the good voice
yeah he's like I need some food so
you're the bird you're the star and I'm
the crocodilla in the water where I get
I clean up the scraps so what's your
voice my my voice is I'm I'm a I'm a
hero so I gota I'm the brains of the
operation the hippos are kind of we're
hippo stupid I'm I kind of organize I'm
like the off's your
voice he's not very good at voice I
don't do Impressions come on it'
probably be just like
this come on give us a voice step out of
your can I can I be an Asian crocodile
no oh my hip balls no because that's
that's the thing that's super [__]
offensive crocodiles in Asia he said gos
that's literally yeah but that is that's
Donald Trump I thought I thought I
thought we're in the circle of trust no
sir we're not we're you can't asoc
stereotypical offensive Asian uh
impression that that was around in the
60s and number one hold on hold on to be
clear it doesn't mean that Asian
crocodiles speak Chinese I was going to
say that that's that's mine speaks
English he just has little Chinese
twangs so did he learn oh ni Rich well
don't no eat licorice that's so that's
how I say make a wish before I kill the
guys before I send the Hipp on them go
oh they a wish you're saying licorice no
I'm saying make a
wish wow we uh I want to apologize this
is sponsored by the clan
apparently we're being funded by crosses
everywhere brought to you by white
supremacy ladies and gentlemen hey it's
my [__] movie it's my movie it's my
movie Donald Trump is funding this movie
he's Donald Trump's Kickstarter for
hungry hungry exactly what else you got
Donald Trump as the crocodile the
crocodile all right next one we got
we're going to eat we're let me just say
something we're going to we're going to
eat we're going to eat
big that's the tagline I'll eat
everybody I'll I'll eat everybody you
know I'm saying a child a child you'll
name it millions and millions of people
Angelina Jolie and [__] Brad Pit
finally for divorce couple key facts
here one Brad Pit was banging a gang
load of Russian hookers I didn't know
that good for him two you're sure yeah
that's that's say yeah uh's being
accused so Angel hired a he hired a she
hired a pi CU she thought something
sketchy might be going she was right so
there's I don't know if it's like
outright confirmed by his people or
anything but so allegedly we'll stick
with that allegedly Russian hookers and
he might have been bang in Mary and
coard who's that uh she was in she won
for Rose she won the Academy Award for
LAN
gor she's a can you I love her she's so
tal he was banging her and then Russian
hores what is it was his co-star
soad he should have a shrine yeah who is
this guy Brad Pit he should have a
shrine he is Brad bit he should have a
shrine in [__] straight downtown
Hollywood yeah there she was in um she
was in uh
Inception [__] love Midnight in Paris
no and how about her Le
she to me she's not sexy she's she's
beautiful she's not sexy Andrew jie drip
you really can't Angelina Jolie drip
sexiness she doesn't she kills me she's
my favorite hold on go up for one second
that looks like um Brad Pit is playing
Robert Redford in a
biopic yeah he does like everything he's
playing a LensCrafter salesman in N
Tucket that's exactly what she looks
like um hired an undercover agent to
fall to this wh house and you you don't
think Al rent was getting his dick
sucked in there too and then snitched on
him I don't know if that's true but ah
If I Was A P are being outlandish claims
right now well when when you say hooker
I mean does Brad bit need to pay for it
I would imagine like you I bet they were
I bet there are high class escorts there
you go and he probably wasn't even
painful you didn't start the air quotes
just until you said escort you did high
class escort yes high class but the high
class was totally she strike Angelina
Jolie and I'm fan but strikes me as very
difficult to be married to and sound
strikes me as probably a little crazy
too but do you know her it's all
speculation isn't it we have no idea
it's not so much speculation because she
could be a great person I I don't like
doing this she is a great person she is
a great person she gave she gives Sly
like a quarter of her money to Charity
she adopted like 19 she's an awesome
person and not to mention the fact that
she's prodigiously talented as a it's
unbelievable just all I'm saying is that
people like that as amazing as they are
can probably be very difficult to live
with uh um you know how was her children
like like a reality
never not so much speculation on my part
but I I know some people who oh [__] off
you you're [__] just pulling stuff I
know oh [__] you no this is all
speculation no no I'm sorry sir it's not
I know people that have been intimate
with her and been with her for and I had
long conversations with them two people
not one but two and that starts back in
um let me think
1990 2001 I think was the first time I
had a conversation about that
so I have I I've had real conversations
and Johnny Lee Miller yep Johnny Lee
Miller and Billy Bob Thor had Billy Bob
thoron her I won't say I I won't mention
Nam but I I have had real conversations
where they have you know but then again
you're right at the same time I think
it's tough at the at the same time just
because I've had like someone saying a
c's a dick man how well do you know him
I don't but I have a friend used to date
him 20 years ago and he was so tough I
would say this that that anybody you
could come up with age anything about
anybody cuz I had um I heard some
something about somebody who was like a
super aess guy that I had always I'm
still a fan of huge fan and somebody
said oh I met him this one time and he
was like kind of a dick and then my best
friend played poker with him and he was
like dude he was the nicest guy in
listen we're everybody is everything
human being are different exactly so
it's like we're all everything what day
did you catch that person I'm talk to
people who are who you know if you've
been in a relationship with somebody
don't take their word for it it's there
are two sides of the story
so I stand correct but also with with
with marriage it's tough too how long
they've been together they're both aess
celebrities he's doing his thing she's
doing his thing they have [__] 17
kids half them are adopted so to is it
difficult I'm sure it is does it mean
she's difficult no it might mean to
together they're they're she does a lot
of good in the world that's she does
she's aw she's awesome she [__] the
movies that she makes they're I think
they're great she's a she's a formidable
human being I I I've always thought she
was an incredible actress she's
impossibly beautiful and she does a
shitload for charity and you know I love
though their their pool of children are
the Multicultural show that Network
comedies have been she adopted from
Cambodia from Molly to all different
places but more importantly like at
least the people like oh they're getting
divorced they made that relationship
worked for how many years that's an
accomplishment that's a big deal in you
don't know how long it's been like you
know what I'm saying like who knows you
know how it goes the other thing is is
uh yeah I don't it's F tough man how how
funny is how how crazy is a world we
live in where there's someone out there
sick of [__] Angelina Jolie I know I
know I said there's no hope for any of
us that's what I think about Jennifer
Anderson with her yes yes yeah that's
the irony of the whole situation anyone
surprised that he's doing it did you did
you see he gets away with it all did you
see the PO we still love him did you see
I love him even more did you see the
post of New York the New York uh post he
show pict uh jenon laughing that was the
cover of the post this morning
classy gee is yeah I um it's he's the
he's kind of Teflon isn't he like any
other guy back that Cad and and we're
all like Russian hookers Mar well he's
Johnny de I I
mean's I'm in it's weird right it's like
George C he's just this he was this
Relentless player for like 60 [__]
years we're just like ah whatever great
sense of humor people love him yeah je
you get cheat on left and right can have
kids everyone's like ah whatever just
dicks well we make decisions up that was
like the joke that I came up with the
Tom Hanks about is like that we forgive
people that we want to forgive yeah and
then we don't forgive people we don't
want to forgive yeah and that's like you
know and these are the types of stories
where everyone's going to take a side
well I think all of us kind of also
realize life it's very hard when you're
Brad Pit to say no to to the world
when you say the world's his oyster no
[__] literally any room he goes into he
can go ah I want to stick my dick in
your mouth yes yeah you know what I'll
tell you this though Tom Hanks I would
say has different but same where Tom
Hanks is beloved I mean he's not the
sexm though yeah different energy but
you know what and and Tom Hanks met Rita
Wilson when he was married um but now
like I don't know what happened with
with in terms of the divorce of that
previous marriage but you know we just
don't look at Tom Hanks like the fact
that this came out I don't think people
are like oh my God people are like
there's a lot of humor that's going
around about with like the you know the
GIF sign lineer the GI sign lineer
whatever about Jennifer Anderson but you
know it's just that not that people
expected from him but they're not
surprised well yeah and it was Tom Hanks
you're right so much of what makes Tom
Hanks appealing is that we trust him we
love him your dad he's like no you know
what he's like your dad's good friend
you can call on if you need to bury a
body all the time man and and Brad Pit
plays a host of different guys he's sexy
he's this man he's dangerous yeah so you
expect it at him like he's an animal
it's bad pit Tom Hanks does I'm like
what the [__] exactly it was like the
Bill Cosby thing where I was like what
the [__] are you talking about he's a
rapist that's the thing let me tell you
this about like this somebody was saying
this about like there's other
celebrities out there who have been
accused of many things that we've been
that we've forgiven very quickly and
then we and then Bill Cosby just for
most people well he's a rapist there's a
difference like to be a 100% agree with
you philander it's one thing when you
were a rapist you know yeah but Bill
Cosby he did terrible things that so
many women we get that but there's been
celebrities who have killed people and
we forgive them uh like who uh Ray Le uh
well you talking about athletes yeah Ray
yeah same thing but uh uh Caitlyn Jenner
Matthew bradick didn't Caitlyn Jenner
ran in in his Hummer her Hummer ran the
back of an older agent lady killed her
it's all good she she she got ANB never
heard about it two months later got ANB
no they paid the family off it's all
good uh [__] uh who's what's Ray J's
uhy Brandy killed a guy did no time we
still buy our records it's all good how
how' I didn't see him ran Ransom poor
dude over like ran into the car it's all
good we're like yeah it's all good man
see 12 celebrities who have killed
people courtesy of BuzzFeed we got Laura
Bush who ran I didn't do this ran a stop
sign crashed into a car killed someone I
don't know who that is Don King killed
some Don killed two different guys in
jail as the leader of a gambling ring
Jesus Christ what else shot one and
stomped another guy to death holy [__]
God
godamn he goes well you know precious of
the ghetto life Jesus Christ Matthew BR
what what car accidents in Ireland yeah
[__] man and there you go Brandy what it
say Brandy car crash uh hit hit the car
in front of her by failing to break in
time and kill the driver in front of her
never took full responsibility but was
never charged with any crime but you
never you know sometimes these when
accidents happen you know it's anci it's
it's one of those ter I'm just saying
you still took someone's life like
Caitlyn Jenner took someone's life and
we're just like ah it's all good man
right didn't mean to what about Keith
Moon that was Dr Keith Moon yeah uh he
ran over his chauffeur and bodyguard
outside a pub in England while while
fleeing from skin heads [__] also not
charged Jesus Sid
Vicious Jason William
who did Jason Williams kill he giving a
torvis house and was playing with a
shotgun that was that was a big thing
yeah yeah but he he he's in prison he
did prison no yeah he yeah he actually
currently in prison shot a guy with the
shot this articles wri by accident H and
Ted Kennedy oh yeah he looks like a
killer TK what else you got
TK next one up we got there's a lot of
[__] going on around UFC 205 right now
so it was rumored to be Connor Alvarez
and it was rumored that it was pretty
much a done deal they just needed to
sign it for whatever reason like both
guys were totally on board it was a done
deal and as of last night it looks like
again rumored to have been a a money
issue but Eddie Alvarez is no longer
fighting Conor M Connor got pulled out
and Eddie has been given khib nurov
which is oh Jesus a significantly worse
match up so from what I hear is Eddie
Alvarez was complaining to the UFC brass
that he wanted more money to fight Conor
McGregor he wanted pay-per-view points
he want a certain amount of money and
the UFC you know Joe Sila was going out
on Shield he went you want to do what oh
no oh oh oh the one of the biggest fight
cards of All Time madon Square Garden
first time UFC's ever been in New York
and you we're allowing you to fight
Conor McGregor as the main event but you
want more money now I'll tell you what
we're GNA do we're gonna pull Conor off
give him probably a bigger fight and
then uh here's khabib Nega murd terrible
match up oh and also those pay-per-view
points not happening really because
neither one of them are draw anymore
enjoy that my Lord here you go you're
going to lose your belt yeah here's a
terrible matchup but this is just
looking at the whole picture that just
looking at the whole picture it sucks
for Conor too okay Conor now you're
going to fight now you want that 155
belt now you got you got to get through
khabib neur nightmare who's going to
beat that guy and he beats himself
unless he gets injured no one's beating
that guy nobody's beating khabib I don't
see it happening right not even close
and for Conor it's the worst match of
about 55 I I think Connor it's a tough
fight but I can see him beating Eddie
Alvarez yeah khib I mean I he's going to
be your champ if so it's very it's very
shortsighted by the UFC right pay Eddie
more money what what do you guys [__]
care M Square G how much again how much
money do you need pay the guy more money
unless he's asking for like 10 million
some ridiculous number give Conor the
belt it'd be great to see him have the
55 and the 45 shortsighted it's the guy
wants more money [__] him put in khib
okay but let's just think about this
there's going to be a ripple effect you
put khib in most likely khabib's going
to destroy Eddie Alvarez still tough
fight but most likely he wins that then
what where's Conor go back to 45 tough
weight class for him 55 he has to fight
khabib now his toughest match up dister
what are you going to do now there's
only super fights for him and he's your
biggest draw so why what what are they
again you got to question just how smart
they are yeah you got to look at the
business plan and someone just need go
let's take egos out of this let's take
our EOS at it how much money does Eddie
want well how much money would we make
if Conor's on the card compared to Eddie
a and then how much would we make in
[__] the next fight with Connor fight
what do you think they're offering Eddie
is there any word on what probably
probably something insulting and he's
the
champion um you might know a little bit
more about this is do you get an
automatic like contract renegotiation if
you become champ it I from I I don't
know what they're doing these days but
it used to be when you became champ you
get this certain bonus there's like a
like a tier that's just like reserved
yeah if you a but like when I sign my
six fight deal they're like if Brennan
becomes champ we'll renegotiate so a lot
of them do renegotiate once become champ
I know they're like I'm champ now what's
up but I know you can't get pay-per-view
points unless like I I remember Ben hon
didn't get pay-per-view points till he's
like three-time defending champ it
depends where you're at on the scale
does that make sense so Eddie can't go I
need pay-per-view points I'm like well
no you're not a draw we're not we're not
giving you anything like Jose Aldo and
you have to get a certain amount of
pay-per-view buys till you get points I
think it's over 300 they get points
khabib versus Eddie is not a 300 buy
pay-per-view that's just not a draw damn
that doesn't make for the MMA purist
it's great before first of all I want to
see Connor fight Eddie I don't want to
see Connor get suplexed by khabib nerov
you think they'll even let him fight him
yeah for sure but he can't fight at 70
anymore you fight at 45 he'd have to
fight him J yeah so Connor tweeted out
just two words today just said beg me so
we but I don't know is is that in
response to is that directed at
Alvarez or is that directed to the
UFC yeah I don't know I don't know and
and and is it I don't know is it
official that Eddie's fighting nothing
signed literally the only thing that's
set for 205 is t-wood Wonder booy but
the other thing Dana White tweeted cuz
someone tweeted at Dana was like yo is
Connor and Eddie for sure and he put no
it's
khabib that's what Dana tweeted yeah and
so the rumor mill is that Eddie won
pay-per-view points they yanked Conor
and put khabib in for this reason W now
now maybe Connor's being difficult in
negotiations for M Square Garden
something like that if he tweets out beg
me it goes more towards that lane but
New York's looking like Kaka though M
looking like [__] big card to only have
one fight signed off on officially and
that would be the main event of the best
that would have been the main event but
you have Woodley vers Wonder Boy again
not not over 300,000 buys not even close
that's amazing khabib you if you could
have Wonderboy Woodley you have khabib
Eddie Alvarez not a draw not a pay-per
it's a huge it'd be a f for the MMA
Pierce I love the matchups that's
fantastic I will 100% buy it and I'm so
crunked for it as far as mainstream
media and getting buys you got a [__]
card son you need Connor on that card
you need Conor on that card who else do
you need on the card you need Weidman
he's from New York you need
Weidman um and I I heard I've I've also
heard even Widing because the way
they're treating alquinta is thinking
about being like I'm not fighting unless
until you treat us all these guys right
I'm not fighting
amazing we'll see yeah a lot of mov
moving parts around 205 who the hell
knows what's going to happen do you mind
if I uh drain this Beaker not at all sir
we're going to piss all right that's it
for current events Bri you got some
dropping knowledge for us got a little
dropping knowledge and uh it's uh from
The New York Times what in the world 10
questions on global quirks uh Evan why
don't you read them off and we'll guess
what they are all right so we are going
to start with all right all over Mexico
City are green rectangles and circles as
small as a window fan or as large as a
trampoline each with four white arrows
directed toward a white dot in the
center these indicate a areas where
public displays of affection are allowed
B Landing areas for drones C areas where
there are no restrictions on political
speech or D areas to gather after an
earthquake I'm going to
go with e all of the above I'm going to
go uh just do that just bro it's all of
it you can't there's no E bro come on
man there's Jonathan no rules kite he's
in the building What the fu um I'm going
to go to uh I'm going to go to the
drones I'm going to go drones too drones
I like drones too even though it's a
little recent let's do it yeah we are
wrong it's for areas to gather after an
earthquake yeah how
the the people just stand in [__]
Circle I didn't you let me finish it's
for people drones ah
together you had to pause you had
what a stupid ass thing people all right
so go ahead this is the next
one all right next one the underrated
humor of Kenyans is often expressed in
euphemisms the Swahili phrase kitu
kidogo literally means a little
something but euphemistically it refers
to a small meal between lunch and dinner
a bribe or Kickback a sexual partner
outside marriage or a second
job uh I have I'm going to go briber
kickback my my Kenyon uh is a little off
um uh I'll go sexual partner outside
marriage also known as a side piece in
the Kenyan culture there you go I would
have chosen that too I'm going with
sexual partner as well yeah but guess
what it's a briber a kickback Jonathan
Kite Jonathan Kite I was born in Kenya
and I should have made that clear I did
not know that I figured Advantage sir
yeah well oh this is great which one of
these do you want BR uh your pick for a
fee postal workers in Finland in
addition to delivering the male will a
mow your lawn B uh tutor your children
in basic math and reading skills C let
you read your neighbors magazines D join
in playing charades finland's national
game uh I'm going to go with uh let you
read your neighbors
magazines uh yeah what he said I you're
losing your interest in this qu yeah
what he said it's your
lawn uh oh
mother keep going
down this is ridiculous try being a
listener in your car right now yeah
might might be a little Let's do let's
do one more let's do one more oh this is
good Chino the food that sustained Inca
armies which is still eaten in the Andes
is made from fermented llama milk mixed
with peanuts uh cornmeal flavor with
alpaca saliva and cocoa leaves potatoes
repeatedly Frozen Tha and stomped on or
cucumber tomato carab squash all natives
of the Andes how did you choose that one
over the household gadgets that will
kill you in South Korea oh that's a good
one that's way better microwave blender
portable CD player or electric fan in
South Korea the people believe that one
of those objects can kill you they
believe one of them can kill you they
people believe this household Gadget can
kill you microwave blender Port player
fan microwave I said microwave it's
actually electric fan it's electric fan
because they that like the idea is that
oxygen gets sucked out of the room oh
wow I don't believe that North Koreans
feel that way by the way I don't Koreans
I don't think I mean South Koreans
believe that North Koreans bu South
Koreans are some of the most
technologically advanced people in the
world I did North Koreans believe that
all those things will kill you
yes house yeah yeah and they will if
they fall from a high enough ledge um I
think I read somewhere this week that
North Korea's version of the internet
has 28 websites total sick yeah but
South Korea we fighter and the kid in
there yeah make sure you got fighter and
the kid.com in there that's it boom
there you go man there's Dr Choice let's
go some fan questions fan questions fan
questions all
right so these are going to be for all
of you guys let's pull these up real
quick first fan question we
got K what's your nationality my mother
is uh Scandinavian Norwegian and danish
and my father is uh well modern day
we're Romanian and Georgian but in the
time it was like Prussia you know who
else was you know what famous man was
Georgian not a very nice
guy uh no who not a nice guy a old
school old school probably the meanest
man to ever live in some ways well Vlad
the Impaler no no no he was from Georgia
real [__] a lot of blood on his
hands
killed a whole bunch of people genas
Khan no no but he is just if there's a
place in hell this guy is just in the
middle of it I mean Donald
Trump no that's very good I mean a lot
of love who Georgia well here's a hint
Georgia is is essentially used to be
part of the Soviet Union yeah it's in
the south of Russia oh is it um is it
uh Stalin Stalin yeah thank you Stalin
boom there we go first fan question
let's start with let's start with one
that the fans have been asking about all
the
time where the [__] is Brendan's money
it's a legit where's his goddamn 12
Grand I just give up on it guys no
listen man we the B bro I was going to
write you that check and I the only
thing is it's spin in my car and we just
haven't gotten to it because I haven't
seen you you know what I'm
saying you know what I mean nah never
seen that
money can't bet you anymore man hey G's
up hey
bro you and I talked about this yeah we
did it's over be quiet nah it's over
listen I don't need you selling me down
the river here okay we talked about this
God damn
it oh God next
question I'm paying Brandon [__] all
right you
[__]
[__] we're going to yeah I'm
going to get a chance to double her
double that up no I'm never betting you
again till I get paid what else you got
hey man I'll pay you I'm gonna write you
the check all right we post on Instagram
yeah we will how much do you think the
fact that you already had a following
and were already somebody before
starting a podcast played into the
success of the podcast and do you think
someone who hasn't made a name for
themselves yet could start a successful
show I don't think it had anything to do
with anything I think it's just I've
been doing standup a long time and
comedy and performing a long time
brenan's I don't think either one of us
were that famous yeah yeah I mean it had
nothing to do with it I mean I think it
did a little bit like people were
intrigued to hear an actual opinion on
the UFC a real fighter a comedian got
together it was a good Dynamic but I it
wasn't like it wasn't like Conor
McGregor and [__] Joe Rogan did a
podcast I would listen to that one yeah
right because then that then you're off
to a fan base you know what I'm saying
we just it's it's our it's the way we
get along and what we we're really
friends and I think you know and we're
yeah so but to answer his question he
says does someone without a name can
they get a big podcast 100% guys do it
all the time all the time I mean sure
it's going to help if you have uh if
you're an analyst on ESPN or Fox
something like that or you're an expert
in you need to bring something to the
table that right that isn't being
brought cuz right now everyone in their
mother has a podcast but the ones that
are successful are like uber successful
in comparison to the ones that aren't
yeah there's there's not yeah you're
right there's no like between there's no
middle class podcasting you're either
doing the damn thing making great money
or you're doing out your mom's basement
with your best friend you both just like
kind of [__] your way through it you
know yeah the podcasting is at an
interesting time right
now
consistency next
one this is a good one hey guys I'm a
young young dude in college any tips to
stop being a [__] and get girls thanks
fam did you did were you a ladies man
and
I did okay I did okay in college I I
probably did much better when I came out
here I was so obsessed University of
Illinois at champagne orbana and there
was a the theater Department there got
on the way of a lot of my relationships
because it's a conservatory type program
you had to audition to get into it it
was super intense and for me I'm such a
driven human being that way that like
when I set my mind on something it's
like a I just go for it 100% And so I
think that that hurt me like I didn't
really like I would go out to the bars
and stuff but I didn't really have a lot
of time that's a good thing not making
it was not an option right dude you
would die 100% I I don't do anything
else well yeah my math skills are in the
[__] Yeah well yeah it's like but but
for me it's like I knew that this is
something that always wanted to do and
so I figured out like what like being a
podcast like what was I bringing to the
table that nobody else was bringing to
the table and so that's what I I didn't
even do Impressions until Jamie Fox had
that audition nothing that's amazing I
was like well they're doing a new Living
Color I'm like well they're probably
only going to take one white guy they're
like and my manager's like well how many
Impressions do you do and I was like one
less than zero yes so he goes well try
them out so I would sit in front of a TV
and my laptop I remember I there's like
s marks on my wooden floor just
listening to people that I'm like well I
could get this guy and my cousin who's
like one of my best friends in the world
who used to live together I run outside
like does this sound like James gandini
like I would I never saw The Sopranos
and then I run in and I would like
listen listen listen and then I'd run
out while he was recording his music
he's a professional rock star but he he
does a lot of writing and stuff well he
is he's a traveling musician rock star
he's a beast of a human being but he
would be like working on music in in the
home we have this huge studio and I
would like run in and be like does this
sound like it and that's what I would do
so there was no failure and so with
college that's how do you music you do
you sing and I sing yeah he and I would
love to we'd love to just like have a
bottle of wine and jam out jam session
[__] best wish I could get in on that
but I can't s play you me P dance I
could dance you get some danc shake your
[__] ass that money maker you shake
your ass while I go I'm in I'm in all
day all day all day with you all day
with all day with ass all day with this
all day with that ass both Us in the car
that would encourage me I know it baby
John oil him up a little bit more oil
big boy up a little more come on pink D
where are you we need more oil [__]
get that patina going get a patina to
his skin I'm down with that man we we
didn't help this young man at all get
girls just be confident man and also be
normal don't be a psycho for for forget
the pickup lines but uh but also if
that's all your focus on you're not
going to make it in anything good at
people I know people I know that are out
chasing girls nonstop you're again
you're Comm with guys like him like me
we're not out chasing
girls on our CU that's what a girl's
interested in a guy who's trying to get
girls yeah cuz that's attractive the guy
who's not doing anything at night and
just chasing girls girls like a man
who's really good at something so build
a skill I don't care if it's playing the
guitar learn something and get really
good at it and you will find answers in
that you'll find life lesson that you
can apply you find some titties in
yourself well yes you find that too but
if you're really good if you can play
the if you can play the piano or the
guitar really well in a year there women
you'll find a girl who likes you you can
have a hoof and a horn if you can play
music there's there's a woman out there
it's but don't be that acoustic guy on
the quad no don't don't bring your
guitar to parties you're my best friend
guy do not be the acus there's nothing
worse dude no one wants ever we don't
want you ever so true man we get it um
yeah closing time we all
know yeah yeah cling time I'm like it's
not closing time it's noon on a Thursday
it is you're under a tree Jesus Christ
the same guy the same guy shows an
affair with a parrot I was just going to
say you're the same guy at a fair who's
a loot player even like back in the
1600s we're like we get it we get it we
get it we get it what else you got it
isn't it's nth yeah it's nth and a
thirth all right next one was a good one
let's talk Halloween costumes you guys
dressing up what will your kids be when
is too old to dress up this guy got a
shitload of questions about Halloween is
it okay to dress how do I get girls is
it okay to dress with my kids when we go
trick-or treating and any memorable
costumes from your past hey bro I don't
[__] know the answer to these
question well I'll tell you right now
I'll tell you right yeah I'll help
there's no limits to Halloween anything
especially have kids you're [__]
right you better dress up make an event
for your kids there's no limits you're
never too old to dress up as long as you
have kids now it's you your grown ass
men
buddies if you have kids or you're a
serial killer cuz those people are just
going to dress it and clowns are never
okay in any situation even for kid
clowns are okaying no kids are I was a
clown as a little kid and like 5 years
old my grandmother made uh me a little
clown costume times were different
killed other kids they were I murder
were different murderer I was that's
when I would did best with the ladies I
murdered the ladies literally literally
tell you 5-year-old clown every
Halloween I I stick with the French
robot just like it was when I was six
just like the picture I random most the
French robot and I threw croissant at
kids all right my Mom hated me that was
your hazing that was that that was your
vandalism I'm going to dress up like
Jonathan Kite oh dude what an honor from
two bro you know we get that's how we
knew we had made it cuz people started
making their own costumes of of the two
girls and me and Sophie oh my God with
Jennifer K that was like when people
posted those I remember we were sharing
them with such Delight to be like oh my
god like people it was awesome yeah
couples would go as as Jennifer and I
and then always blind and brunette or
they'd find a wig and the two girls
would go two girls and they'd make the
costume it's kind of a lame costume
though all due respect like you're
dressing up like your favorite sitcom
well let me just say this let me just
say this if I could rip this off and
throw it on the ground and walk the [__]
out of here after that I would but I
respect you I apologize I
feel your voice is getting very high
right now I just feel yeah um yeah you
know what I I'll tell you this year um
I'm going to go so Matt Moy who plays um
who's one of my favorite people on
planet Earth and he plays Han Lee on the
show he's a little guy we're going to go
as um Sherlock Holmes and Dr Watson I
like that creative well would you go I
like when people go as a team I like
that I was a I was a I was a salt shaker
my my buddy in uh college was the pepper
shaker I love I thought for you had to
say Shaker cuz if you had said salt and
Peppa we'd be like you guys went us two
black girls no were black and we put on
asses that's not going to go over well
that's I was a salt shaker he was a
pepper shaker Prett it was fun cuz I
went to I told you I went to the H
Halloween costume in LA and the guy
shows up everybody's dressed in cool
outfits and this guy's in a naked suit
with a huge dick and and yarn for pubic
hair and he was really big anyway and
and he walks around I go I go who are
you he goes I'm [__] this guy that's
hilarious like the best costume ever you
in La it's tough though because there's
always someone who's like yeah my my
best friend's the makeup artist on uh
[__] Walking Dead it's like all right
yeah you [__] went all out man what
were you eight n hours in the chair make
make I bought this at [__] Halloween
2016 store like I look like an [__]
now my I go to a costume party every
year where my friend hosts this amazing
party well this will be the second year
but I hope to continue to be friends
with her and um they have a costume
contest and it is like it is a it is a
real reality show oh in La no no it's
it's in uh New Orleans oh God still yeah
but it is sick I mean it's the stuff
that I saw the coolest costume I ever
saw in my life was last year this makeup
artist came as this um doll as a full
life-size porcelain doll holding a doll
that was it was the same and each of
their heads was upside down Wow and his
head he was able to paint it with the
hair I mean it was like one of those
things where you needed to like take a
second to to really drink this guy in I
appreciate like that Budd you know who
goes balls deep on Halloween our buddy
Cody Donovan really one we we we go to
this part in Denver we used to go this
party every year I forget what it's
called but we go this Halloween party my
brother dressed up as a penguin beat up
another guy because he was a penguin we
were drinking and he wanted to be the
only he wanted to be the only Penguin at
the party so he went as an alcoholic
yeah he went as an alcoholic dressed as
a penguin ran into a guy who's dressed
as a penguin started talking [__] to him
that's the funniest thing I've ever
heard in my life he beat up another
penguin cuz he the only penguin wait
penguins are friends though my brother
wasn't feeling not not not loner wolf
penguin deci to
slap not the Wolverine of penguin them
out slap the guy loner wolf penguin uh
anyways but so Cody my buddy our buddy
Cody him and his girl at the time he was
Frankenstein and he painted him his
entire self green had this vintage
costume on had the mask his girl went as
the bride and we got over there [__] I
probably got there like 8 or n o' he's
been doing it all [__] dat and he was
exhausted like he was like dude I don't
know if I can go to the party but he
looks so real I was like well let's just
get a couple drinks and figure it out
let's just get some shs put my
Instagram but his he was the butcher
from uh [__] uh gangs in New York oh
yeah build the butcher I always said I
would want to as a good as soon as so
let me tell you this I said back then I
go cuz I've grew grow the beard out for
the show I said the first year where
we're not on I'm going to shave this
part out with till Halloween and then
I'll do build the butcher with the
mustache I forget Cody's Instagram but
Cody Donovan his uh build the butcher
really [__] so legit I love that
character get yourself a piece of meat
on the way out yeah you know she's not
really my mother dude that movie is so
oh my God he's good I love it when he
goes he goes what's your name and and L
on CER goes Amsterdam he goes Amsterdam
I'm New York yeah dude he's so so five
fingers make a fist oh wait you come
together make a fist dude
[__] he was so good in that oh my God
you know what though he didn't win
because Adrien Brody from The Pianist
won and it was like such a huge you know
it was Monumental where it's like I felt
like to to me gangs in New York the
first two-thirds of that is one of the
best movies ever made a little bit the
end it it it when the elephant runs
across the screen even the characters in
the movie are kind of going what the
[__] like like they and the flaw though
the fundamental flaw of that movie was
that that you cared more more about
Daniel de Lewis than you did about about
Leo AB so much dra you were dra his
magnetism you can't have him play
anything other than the lead because his
talent is just so magnetic it's a vacuum
he stayed in that character the entire
he I know he used to lift and he would
call Liam niss priest Valen yes and they
built that whole in Italy they built the
whole Community there it's such a rich
my cousin I always talk about this film
um I I they shot her in Italy they sh in
Italy i' probably seen the movie I'm not
kidding you 50 times my friends and I
have this joke where it's like if they
don't if they're not physically looking
at me they're assuming I'm watching
Gangs of New York I've seen it that many
times and one time they text me like you
want to come out and I just took a
screenshot of what I was doing and they
all text me back cuz it was just me
watching him wrapped in the American
flag going how do I they act fearsome
acts so anyway but the thing is like
with him you you did he he was so much
more interesting and his group like John
C Riley all those other guys they they
were so interesting than like Leo's like
young scrappy little rascals it
overshadows it dramatically like you
don't even think like Leo it's like
whatever also you know also also Daniel
de Lewis fought his dad fair and square
and now he's come back to get revenge
and it's like well you know you're not
really you haven't earned your place in
this group and now you're trying to
avenge your father but I actually am
more sympathetic to the guy who cut his
own eye out cuz he didn't he goes this
was a great man the only man I ever
killed worth remembering that was his
dad and and cut his own eye out because
I can't remember he looked away he
looked away and he I love him when he
Taps it with the with the knife he just
Taps his eye cuz he's like not oh he's
unsettled dude well there's so many
choices in the beginning when you first
see him he takes his foot and he like
brushes the snow the way that horses do
so they can feel how it's going to feel
to walk on it they're like it's an
instinctual thing and he does the same
I'm like the choices that he makes in
that movie are perfect he's a [__]
genius what a beast anyway last question
so we hope we answer that about Daniel
de
Lewis Lu I'm not sure how many of them
were about D good luck with good luck
getting that accomplished it's a beast
oh my God I love it yeah gr out a a
mustache obviously and you're gonna have
to rip your eye out yeah rip your eye
out have to and then you have to [__]
Carmen Diaz so C Diaz sry and Carmen
Diaz and car twin the drag the drag
queen version of Cameron Diaz Carmen
Diaz is unbelievable huge dick in the
you should see him in something about
Mar push his dick to the side hold his
balls up sorry no I wish we were I wish
there' just been silenced for 10 seconds
I was going to do that try
again balls you can't do that you know
this man I know but I like what else you
got I like to beat a dead horse all
right who in the room has ever had a
pumpkin spice latte and what's your most
basic [__] guilty pleasure dude [__]
love avocado toast lavender ice cream
and [__] pumpkin spice lattes I don't
[__] with any of it I don't either I
love avocado toast having some right now
you look like you like evado I don't
like it I love it um I've never had I
don't like let me let me correct you sir
um I don't I've never had a pumpkin
spice latte in my life I'm not a
Starbucks kind of guy I'm not either I I
I like that they give their employees
insurance and I I like I believe in
their uh which I think is a big thing
because Papa John if you're listening um
this for you Papa John this for you papa
hope you listening Papa I'm coming for
you met that I met that guy one time in
Utah dude I like Starbucks it gets a bad
rap but I I just I live by a place I
like local coffee I I tend to support
the little guy I really like that and
we're living out here I think that we
are lucky enough to afford that there's
not a Walmart in my neighborhood which I
don't like anyway um this is for you
Walmart and um Walmart and paa John
happened and another thing I bad on all
these corporations and another thing
they sponsors this is for you Nike we're
insane Nike we're about live though I
live uh like in the heart of Hollywood
like right by the
Grove my address let me give you my
address and my gay code what the [__]
yeah papa John whoops your ass um cfee
I'm coming to you Papa John I'll bring
it to you what's your coffee shop
there's this one called Andante it's um
it's run by this guy who's uh it's
Japanese over style and he's um half
Korean half Japanese and uh when I I
went to Tokyo a couple years ago it's
the best cup of coffee I've ever had in
my life and I went to Italy the same
summer
and it was yeah I was just trying to hit
up the Access of Evil tour guides and um
went to Germany 6 months later and so
the thing was like the Cofe indry
[__] good inp where you're at where
you're at now though is the same it's
amazing and right down the street is
this place called Blue Bottle which I
believe is from San Frisco bottles off
of it Kenny and there's but there's one
let me tell you this if you have a heavy
I do four shots look at my face listen
you just like you know what you're doing
you're screwing in a light bulb I can't
tell what you're no no I know what
you're doing you're grabing tent yeah
yeah I couldn't say that yeah but uh I
would say this if you have with blue
bottle if you do a double or like if you
do a single espresso with milk it's
great but if you do more than that the
coffee is too bitter it doesn't the
acidity anyway but um the Andante is my
favorite cup of coffee in town have you
been to
intelligencia yeah yeah they have it in
Chicago
yeah Chicago and what do you think CH
chicag I thought I wonder if it's the
water that we use out here here I wonder
if they use filtered water I don't know
and I have not I I had it one time I
thought it was good I've had it in Chico
Dante it's well that's what their slogan
is we're not UND Dante um but the you
get you you get just the drip or you get
a cappuccino or latte I get a ice latte
I get four shots okay nice latte hey
Brandon come on give him a chance man
what come on well he I was the Japanese
and the Italian [__] listen iced coffee
is for terrorists you can't taste a good
coffee when it's iced I I have to do it
that way because when I drink a hot
beverage I sweat like a man who thinks
he's going to be found out about
something and so the moment it's like
drinking nobody consumes soup that fast
unless you're in um unless you're in
communist Russia I'm talking to you
communist Russia B on
everybody all of our sponsors dude these
are all D they pay our bills I'm coming
for you um I'm For You Russian ruple and
um the thing is so I I just like that
because I need a cold beverage like this
water I keep these in the fridge man I
just I got to drink have have you had uh
the [__] Nitro brew from Starbucks I
you don't go there but that Nitro it's
good I've heard it's very good the ply
vist one is one of the first ones to do
it man that [__] that'll get your crunk
but intelligencia is great Phil's Coffee
is my number one the pour over at Phil I
wonder though is that because they're
using cream and that is that what makes
it good no I don't put cream in my
coffee right very rarely no no excuse me
sir the cream they everyone uses the
same [__] cream no but cream if they
they put a lot of cream in there it can
be like no no you know you order it
yourself right they don't put you can
say I want little cream medium cream a
lot of they never just do cream you got
to tell sorry you know what man this
coffee conversation is over drink you
like blue bottle you only drink ice
cream and you don't know [__] listen I'm
coming for you I'm you no Brandon I just
call you Brandon I just call you out I'm
like done let me no no there's no drip
at um at
Andante it's it's all pour over yeah I
know but 20 minutes you should get a
black pourover well they have like 10
different kinds I'll go there [__]
now where we going to L let's go no
we're going figure out I'm going to take
you B money I'm going to take you and
then whatever it's on me all right you
called me B money we're back in the
friend zone brother I'm getting B and
then a dollar sign yes if you like
Andante you just get Andante I'll just
get John you're going to be hanging out
you're in the abini fight club now you
know that brother can I tell you
something we're not supposed to talk
about it because the fight club but
um I have never wanted more anything
more in my life than to be in a fight
club can I tell you something you just
got jumped in you just got jumped in
you're you mention Blue Bottle nice
coffee though I'm we Jared Leto of this
fight club gorgeous by the way tell tell
them hold on tell them who Jared Leto is
BR tell spared animal that's a spirit
animal you're in dude you're in by the
way that's a spirit animal and he called
me B money we haven't jumped anybody in
since Michael raport we're kick that's
in good company I love we don't have a
lot of people in the ab Fight Club we
haven't even mentioned abin Fight Club
then this part it's going to sting a
little we got to see your piece got to
see your pece taking a piss I'm just
going to glance over make sure you're
all right show which like now you have
to say we he didn't I did cuz well I
didn't know he extended the offer I
didn't know it's like uh you know yeah g
a New York but you got Norwegian you got
some Hungarian in you probably working
with something I love have you been to
Hungary no I'd love to go Budapest I've
been there a couple times should go
together such I'm at this is okay I'm
trying to get weird how you haven't been
there oh bro I'm just like no I have
been there all right all right I'm
asking him but it's speech budapes budap
which was spared in the war dude you
guys should talk about all the places
you've been and then kind of you give
them the history on all the places and
you give yours and we should get coffee
on another podcast I was just going to
say this is inception podcast it's a
podcast we a podcast it's on the post
fighter in the all right brother where
can they find you Twitter Instagram
obiously Two Broke Girls Jonathan Kite k
i t Jonathan boom stand up man of
[__] many ter yes come see me at the
Algonquin theater September 30th wait a
minut i there for are you the
30th what the the [__] fin the kid while
you guys are listening to us we will be
flying to San Jose that [__] is sold
out so don't bother getting tickets
first time sold out in October we're in
Oxnard and Brea and then uh November
Palm Beach California uh Palm Beach
Florida 11th and 12th and on the 10th
we're in Atlanta those tickets go on
sale Friday I see you dirty birds asking
Friday for Atlanta November 10th this is
the fin kid we're out